there are many interesting and weird
locations found all throughout the work
of HP Lovecraft and those who followed
in his footsteps outside of the dream
lands we've not really discussed any of
these so today we'll take a look at some
of the others
the first location on today's list is
Arkham a fictional town in Massachusetts
the town takes a role of a central hub
being mentioned in many of Lovecraft
stories as well as many other authors at
first glance you'd be forgiven for
thinking that Arkham is an ordinary
run-of-the-mill town but there's a
reason it pops up in so many stories the
town is shrouded in mystery from the
outside but to those that live there
this mystery is full of dark legends and
acts of evil that the people have had to
endure the disappearance of children
became commonplace especially amongst
the poorer families with most being used
in rituals and blood sacrifice the
town's a main point of interest is the
Miskatonic library which first appears
in the stories the picture in the house
and Herbert West to reanimate er the
library also housed one of the few
copies of the Necronomicon many believe
that the inspiration for Arkham came
from Salem because of its occult history
and weird occurrences Arkham is
essentially a central hub for the
supernatural what appears to be nothing
more than a regular town is far more
fishy that meets the eye
speaking of fishy towns we can now segue
nicely into the seaport town of
Innsmouth much like Arkham this small
town has a history of strange
occurrences the buildings are rundown
and decaying many who once called this
town home have moved on the town itself
was founded in 1643 and before the
American Revolution it was known for
building ships as the years went by and
due to several shipwrecks and the war of
1812 only one fleet remained captained
by a bird marsh the head of one of the
founding families during his travels
Marsh came across a religion practiced
by Polynesian Islanders but he would
later adapt
into the cult known as the esoteric
order of Dagon
shortly after this the town's fishing
industry began to boom out of nowhere
almost as if someone or something had
given them a supernatural hand the Year
1846 is where things really started to
go downhill officially it was said that
a plague struck the town which caused
death and mass depopulation now we know
this was just a cover-up Martian the
esoteric order of Dagon had two beings
that they worshiped at the center of
their religion Father Dagon and mother
Hydra eventually they struck a deal to
give the town limitless amounts of gold
and fish but with such a deal comes a
grave sacrifice the deep ones were
summoned to Innsmouth and in exchange
for riches they would sacrifice the
people of the town in their name members
of the cult took a series of oaths
before joining these were secrecy and
loyalty to the cause with the final oath
being to marry and sire or bear a child
with a deep one this Mixson of species
is what created the deformed hybrids
which would eventually become deep ones
when they came of age making the journey
back into the sea to be with their fishy
brethren the order suffered their first
big blow when the authorities began
investigated in the town and arrested a
bird and many of his followers the Deep
Ones then not receiving their sacrifices
and offerings retaliated and attacked
the town those who remained continued on
without Obed and interbreeding between
deep one and human continued until the
town next came under investigation in
1927 this time after years of research
the authorities planted explosives in
The Devil's reef just off the coast of
Innsmouth and once these were detonated
they plan to arrest the remaining
members of the order the members of the
order however mysteriously disappeared
leaving us wonder and if they were
killed in the explosion or whether they
just made the journey to the seabed
Innsmouth is a town ravaged by greed and
the shady dealings of those who would do
anything
for it to thrive and prosper if your
interest has been piqued by this rather
fishy town or the deep ones the story
you have to read is the shadow over
Innsmouth the town known as Dunwich also
gets a mention today and not just
because the dunnage horror is one of my
favorite Lovecraft stories but because
it's a town with a not so
straightforward pronunciation without
any context it's fairly reasonable to
assume that the town was called Dunwich
but Lovecraft was a fairly big
Anglophile and there are many towns in
his work as well as just in general that
were named after towns back in England
one of those towns happens to be Dunwich
which is located in Suffolk and is
actually pronounced dunnage outside of
the name Daanish is also located in
Massachusetts in an area that is
commonly referred to as Lovecraft
country it's another run-down and mostly
abandoned rural town the residents
however are very superstitious not
particularly smart and well in bread the
only story Lovecraft mentions dunnage in
is in the dunnage horror and it's a
story I highly recommend you read if you
haven't already done so moving away from
Massachusetts we have what is known as
the nameless city which ironically is
its name the city itself is a ruin found
in the Arabian Peninsula and Lovecraft
does make reference to the Mesopotamian
region of child aya which later became
Babylon these ruins were once a great
city built by a race of reptilians that
predated humans the description given is
somewhere in between the body of an
alligator and a seal the architecture of
the city suggests that they were unable
to stand on two legs or at least prefer
to crawl on all fours low ceilings and
rooms that are impossible for humans to
stand up in reinforces theory the
inhabitants of this city originally
lived on the coast but ventured further
into the desert as the sea began to
recede there are two main parts to this
city the portion above ground where we
see the ruins is what we label as the
manes
and then we have the portion below
ground which is essentially a series of
burial chambers
it's believed a few survivors still
remain in this underground portion but
it's never described in any detail other
than being filled with a blinding light
the underground tombs and the ancient
language found on murals suggests that
these small reptilian creatures at least
possess what resembled human
intelligence we don't really know if
they were wiped out by another species
or if they just died on the city film
the story which shares its name with the
city also introduces Abdul al has read
the author of the Necronomicon though at
this point we don't really know him by
name the nameless city was described by
Lovecraft as one of his favorite stories
so going give that one a read if you
want to hear more about lizard people
and the origin of the Necronomicon
Carcosa is another ancient city this
time located on a planet outside of our
solar system it's also one of the many
additions by authors inspired by
Lovecraft in this case Ambrose Bierce
and Robert W Chambers it's first
appearances in Bierce his short story an
inhabitant of Carcosa this story follows
a man who is lost and suffering from
some kind of memory loss as he travels
through what he describes as forests and
deserts he realizes that he is standing
in the ruins of ores once the great and
famous city of Carcosa leading us to
believe that for some reason the city
was destroyed
Robert W Chambers then makes reference
to Carcosa in his story the king in
yellow it's a dark and mysterious city
where a strange eerie curse lingers
despite how small Carcosa is in terms of
importance in the mythos it's been
referenced several more times over the
years it appears as a planet in the game
Mass Effect 3 and there's a temple in
the show true detective it even appears
as the name of a city in Georgia
Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire
the city can be found on the east coast
of Essos within the mountain of Mourne
which is known as the city of winged men
it's also ruled by a sorcerer who claims
to be the 69th year
Emperor so even here we get the idea
that Carcosa is no ordinary city and
once again is shrouded in mystery and
magic considering how many Lovecraftian
references martin makes in his work it's
not a huge stretch to say the Yellow
Emperor might be a reference to Robert W
Chambers king in yellow another author
who made a large contribution to
Lovecraft's mythos was Clark Ashton
Smith who wrote a series of stories that
were classified as the hyperborean cycle
which brings us nicely to our next
location Hyperborea now some of you may
recognize the name and that's because it
appears in the work of the ancient
Greeks the Hyperborean were a group of
giants who lived in the northern region
of hyperborea just beyond Thrace in
Ashton Smith's work hyperborea is a
continent found in the Arctic before the
Ice Age turned hyperborea into an icy
wasteland it was a warm and tropical
place with jungles that were home to the
dinosaurs and a species of Yeti known as
the voor me the voor me were sadly slain
when the first group of settlers
migrated from the south and built hyper
boria's first capital city Comorian the
city was built from granite and marble
with enormous walls and towering spires
the people of Comorian were forced to
flee this city and build a new one from
scratch when its destruction was
foretold at the hand of the old one
Safa guha hyperborea was home to
numerous creatures and deities known as
the old ones who would take the form of
animals south agora as we mentioned
earlier was a giant potbelly toad who
lived underground until the continent
iced over which is when he fled at lack
Necker was a giant spider with a human
face it also lived underground or its
span an enormous web which connected the
awakened realm to the Dreamlands
when this web is finished many believed
that the world will come to an end as
the lines between the two realms have
been permanently blur
rim shake earth is a giant white worm
that travels on an iceberg freezing any
ships it comes across in a permanent
cold the goddess known as eun day who
takes the form of an elk is believed by
many to be the wife of Niall r30 there
are also many formless deities which are
just liquid masses perhaps the most well
known inhabitant of Hyperborea is the
Wendigo God ethic WA who journeys
between this world and many others a
hyperborea was a lush and once budding
paradise before the ice age created a
continent that resembles and nothing
more than an icy wasteland so I guess
what better way to finish them with the
corpse city of early a well at least
that's how I pronounce it similar to how
Cthulhu is supposed to be pronounced
claw Lu earlier' has some rather weird
alien pronunciations to it first appears
in Lovecraft's most iconic story the
call of cthulhu a sunken city deep under
the Pacific Ocean where Cthulhu himself
lays in his eternal slumber it's
described as a hideous crown Citadel
made up of large statues strange
hieroglyphics and images so disturbing
they can't be explained the city appears
in one rich one particular which I'm not
going to attempt to say but translated
it means in his house at early a dead
Cthulhu waits dreaming in stories that
came later the city was also thought to
be the home of cthulhu's daughter
Cthulhu where she waits hiding for her
father to wake protected by the great
star spawn weird alien underwater cities
aren't exactly my thing but I can
understand the appeal when the horror
factor
there are numerous planets mention but
these are often obscure and not by
Lovecraft himself in any real detail the
planet that he does mention a few times
is yogge earth this planet was known for
being home to a dark entity that would
rise from its pits to consume anything
in its path
so not many other species stuck around
when they visited as I mentioned at the
start of the video the Dreamlands are
heavily referenced by Lovecraft in his
dream cycle and they do contain some of
his most unique and weird locations so
I'll leave a link to that in the
description as well as an end screen if
you'd like to watch that if you have any
more interesting locations you'd like to
share or you'd just like to tell me
which ones were your favorite then let
me know in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained